but though it's stars deal with look
what the Kardashians and these people
deal with where people get on and father
just ignore now they just your turn yeah
but yeah now YouTube videos have this
[ __ ] great family little kids and
some of that they sang Baba O'Riley it's
so [ __ ] good and I sang like come
together but he turns to comments off
you can't comment on it
comments on YouTube are done he's like
no comments so he just puts it up and
you got likes it was so great like 91
dislikes get the [ __ ] out of here
it was so good yeah it's a tough border
like is I'm with you with freedom of
speech and our amendment and right so
you have to have that but at a certain
point if it doesn't help anything and
it's just negative I don't know why we
would support that well when it comes to
trolling like there it shouldn't just be
the Wild West know the way you do it is
I think that a company that you use so
YouTube what we are to do this YouTube
Instagram they take a lot of heat for it
but they will censor you if you are they
will take you off youtube I mean they
will take you off if you are being this
insulting right no no they will people
have been taken off you yes no arms of
service where if you breach it yeah to
much of literally you don't get taken
off YouTube all time beggin Diana's
monitor and some but if they upload a
video
trolling someone but not because common
well no comments to like twitter twitter
when you say certain bad things i mean
what's his name is on racist stuff some
like that but if you're just trolling
they're not going to sometimes though
it's not racist stuff somebody's like
just insulting [ __ ] which was what jack
dorsey took so much [ __ ] for because he
runs a huge company there are people
underneath him that were like deeming
some of them these things to be well
have you seen like well what instagram
did so kids aren't so glued to and put
all their value on this game it's you
can't see likes anymore right like you
can't wait you have any followers i
wasted they're wasted there they were
talking about that right to get away for
a while which i thought was brilliant
i don't know if it has to be a law i'm
saying the company itself can create
their own rules social rules right which
they do have
but they get [ __ ] for it too so so in
the so now you stop well using youtuber
Instagram because I can't hate on
someone well YouTube as an automatic
they just wrote an article about this
they have an automatic deletion it's an
algorithm to leads if you insult the
Chinese party with two particular
phrases 50 cent party and another thing
it automatically goes all Chinese saying
nice about the Chinese comics party so
that's an algorithm that was deemed by
somebody at YouTube or some people as
deemed derogatory torch I knees 50 cent
party for whatever reason that camera it
was a you you joined the party for 50
cents of something about that but so so
there's a there's Google was contacted
by The Spectator or someone say asked
him for comments I haven't gotten back
to him yet but they noticed that there
were certain phrases that would caught
him out yeah promises it again now we're
dealing with sticky shoot because they
they're taking a lot of [ __ ] for it so
what but I do agree that what I can you
know I really can't do any look I think
if a bunch of teenagers a bunch of like
well because we'd all of y'all's are
ganging up on one twelve-year-old we
have to do something about it and if
it's cyber it's bullying if you saw them
doing it in the school yard line you'd
be like hey but what's the wildest I
don't do anything yeah well it's hard to
combat it I guess I guess you could
block everybody yeah I mean you as
parents you'd have to tell your kid like
there's a separation between like don't
take it seriously okay you can't them
you know what the problem is social
media is so new we don't know the
repercussions well we're seeing this
suicide rate super high we know some
celebrity stuff some super they suffer
from depression because of the comments
they get yeah this is like the new CTE
we'll see what happens we have friends
who've who've dealt with it and gone
into deep depressions just from the
comments and control dude
you know you put something out there
hope you know it says just don't read
the comments yeah okay I know I do man
like really good at it but then
sometimes your slipper but it's like do
you want to dive into that pool like you
know what's there like very rarely do
you ever go into YouTube comments and
you're like I feel great I'm glad I
didn't ever I want to do this sketch
more y'all had a great bit of YouTube
comments oh I want to do this once get
to where it's like I'm saying it's like
Lord of the Rings I'm saying goodbye to
my family
the village like I have to go to the
YouTube comments
I never I've never once read of YouTube
come no I've never have I don't read
them but the problem is I have family
members that'll read it oh dude oh and
they're like these folks both of my a I
don't wanna hear yeah my mom would call
me she'd be like I saw you uploaded that
video do you read that one guy 9/2 says
suck my dick yeah yeah mom I read it I
don't do you do mom yeah when I was like
I was gonna shitty TV show one time yeah
but my my mother would read all the
comments she would read this is before
social media she would read the critic
logs and she read the critics and she'd
be so mad that she would write the
critics back a letter I'm like this is
that oh don't worry about it
the critic first of all it's kind of
right number one number two relax
they'll be funny the critic writes a
retraction like after being contacted
some good point if we're doing so much
work needed it takes so much work to do
this needs they're so spiteful I'm like
well listen this is a business and
they're kind of right yeah you well
maybe my dad you get you gotta stay out
of comments man if you if you're not
sound takes on the road if you're not
sold on the road no one's watching
podcast and you'll have a fall on
Instagram you're gonna hate on for yeah
and your fans will follow you like the
ones who don't like you who gives a [ __ ]
but like you keep putting content out
your Fanta gravity oh yeah weird the
bigger you get the worse it's gonna get
yes that's that's gonna be 72 it's gonna
be 8 well really 90/10 that's just felt
good about percent i bill burgers I
can't believe say cuz you can say that
you can say everyone you guys [ __ ]
that they ate people on Twitter they
hate you're the ones that's not relying
like I really like I've been getting a
little more and that's just I've
realized I'm kind of happy about it
where like obviously you don't want to
get trolled or hate on but it's just a
testament that you're getting bigger
yeah it's just by sheer statistics not
everyone's gonna like you and that just
means you're reaching more people so if
you're getting more hate it just means
you're like your reach is yeah sometimes
the comments are helpful like I see I
hate when people say though cuz for me
what I
rogon one time I did an Indian I did an
Indian accent and it's a solution brown
face and let me know that's not the
thing we do anymore I don't do that my
pockets
I don't do the brown face I don't deny
maduro okay but the guy said a guy goes
all the guy said was he goes hey Brian
just keep in mind that some Indian
people actually listen to Rogen and when
you do those comments it's kind of a
bummer I [ __ ] I I went that I get I'm
hurt this guy's feelings yeah I was like
I'll never do that again
I'll never do it just didn't Donna me
you know sometimes when it's couched
like that too just like this is how I
felt I still love you or whatever yeah
okay I was like Ilana come out like [ __ ]
you yeah you're gonna be on the yes
we're not gonna take the note but if
you're like you know I'm Indian and that
makes me feel you know maybe buddy Slade
me you guys just keep minds to you yeah
just keep in mind Indian people like
myself listen to you and you know it's
kind of drug story it's kind of a bummer
cause like I'm so sorry I swear to God I
know I I can tell you all about Indian
culture my sister was born in Bombay a
picture of me getting ticket I wrote two
paragraphs if I was like huh this is a
long time ago and I've never forgot it
it was the book back when Rogan was I
was doing Rogen's podcast in his in his
not his garage but in his he had this
shitty room yeah
like Robin 1.0 yeah literally read ban
was the pretty not even I did Brogan's
podcast when I was just he and I with
two shitty mics like back in the [ __ ]
way way day Oh crazy should you see that
you know what it was it was when I said
to him the Internet is only 5,000 days
old and he went his and I go isn't that
crazy that's how long ago I did I said
the Internet's only 5,000 days old and
it was thank you everybody
what else hey Brian but when you do
stuff like when you do the Asian accents
and you're just joking around it's
actually funny though so some people
don't it's funny with in depending on
the cut and all you did on the anybody I
don't know if you were doing like go
Slurpees you know what I was talking
about how they that the in it like
India's got a billion people and they
don't win a lot of Olympic medals maybe
sets isn't about not being as athletic a
country I don't know what I said okay I
said I can beat up the whole country
something like that whatever it was was
it wicked it wasn't cool and I didn't of
course I didn't mean anything mean but I
didn't even know what I was doing until
somebody said well my brother said we'll
get emails and be like I feel bad for
chin and cat when Brenda and Bryan do
Asian accents or whatever
yeah that's trust me if I thought it was
bad to do him from we wouldn't be doing
it well they weren't okay with her we
heard them it also helps a Katan and Jen
are American I'm not which it was yeah
yeah I'm Americanized we're gonna say
for him oh yeah I found that like the
better you are at a foreign accent even
if you're not that race if you nail it
all is forgiven
it's pitch perfect yeah if you're a
white and you do an Asian accent people
don't give a [ __ ] well like the further
you are if it's an approximation people
are like Oasis well if you're right on
July John Daniel Johnson doing a crypto
joe yeah joe is so good she's so spot-on
through I did my African accent about
the Rhino thing I don't know if you've
seen it
this comic who's up he's African he's
from [ __ ]
he's from about you city he was over
there he was from Ghana or something and
he came out to me he goes dude I was
ready to go bad on you the minute I saw
you talking about Africa and when I
heard your accent and the words you were
using in the placement and he goes mad
respect yes I was scared lowdown lingo
blackface I sure did I do it in
blackface and that's but that's you know
yeah it was but it you're right you're
walking right as it goes you took the
time to really study the cadences yeah
and I'm also talking about how this guy
embarrassed me because he was smart in
that way it shows it's kind of a love
letter then rather than like a loose
approximation that's how someone certain
people speaks it's nothing wrong with
doing that yeah like Santino's how you
heard Santino's Indian accent no it's
pretty good yeah I mean I'm not I don't
know but it sounds pretty don't know any
redhead minions yeah yeah this bit at
the Laugh Factory where he would say he
was adopted by an Indian family and
that's why he talked that way but he
went on stage that way and he did like
six minutes just talking about like how
he's like a ginger he's okay you should
be censored know what else right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue oh
what's gonna happen what are you gonna
do use some of that boxing you've been
doing
[Laughter]